it was one of his first promises as
president I intend to close Guantanamo
and I will follow through on it on his
second day in office he signed an
executive order to close the military
prison for good within one year but
seven years since that signing and 14
years since its opening Guantanamo Bay
is still not closed why let's back up
real quick as part of the so-called war
on terror george w bush opened the
prison in 2002 to hold suspected enemy
combatants a total of 780 muslim men and
boys have been imprisoned there but the
u.s. is only considered 8% of them al
Qaeda fighters in fact most of the
detainees had just been in the wrong
place at the wrong time and wound up at
the prison without charge or trial what
they got instead was a jail sail out of
prison infamous for harsh interrogation
torture and hunger strikes a place that
critics say has become a breeding ground
for enemies and a place that doesn't
reflect the values of American justice
in fact the military tribunals set up
there to try some detainees were so slow
and unjust that six military prosecutors
protested or resigned and get this more
detainees have actually died at
Guantanamo than have been convicted by
those tribunals and even though the
majority of detainees have been
transferred over the years dozens still
remain including many who've actually
been cleared to go so what happened
Obama well he seemed some major
obstacles one of them the Pentagon see
the detainees that are cleared for
release have to be transferred to
another country or repatriated but a
recent investigation accuses the
Pentagon of purposely D railing and
delaying that process and keeping the
detainees locked up but perhaps the
biggest obstacle in Obama's efforts has
been Congress they've also made it
difficult for other countries to accept
detainees and they've restricted
transfers to the u.s. see to close
Guantanamo Obama says that the detainees
designated as too dangerous should be
moved to US prisons but Congress has
come
distantly prohibited him from doing that
citing security concerns after all a
government report said that some
detainees released to other countries
rejoined the fight but even those on the
Left say moving these detainees to the
u.s. is wrong because it sets a
dangerous precedent of indefinite
detention in our own country and finally
a lot of people blame Obama accusing him
of simply lacking political will
they say he prioritized other things
like Obamacare or the Iran nuclear deal
over actually closing Guantanamo in this
past November Obama even signed a
defense bill that limits his ability to
transport detainees to the US so what's
left for the president he said he can
use executive powers to speed up the
transfer process but if he didn't do
that seven years ago will he muster the
political will to do it now if he
doesn't the fate of Guantanamo will fall
to the next president not one of the GOP
candidates says they'll finish what
Obama started and most are actively for
keeping it open and amidst all these
years of political wrangling let's not
forget those who paid the ultimate price
the detainees there is still some men
who've never been charged with a single
crime now entering their 15th year in
the prison not knowing their fate
so how much longer will we continue to
detain these men at the expense of our
reputation and well immorality